i have the perfect idea we're going to
use doll e2 to visualize perfectly
photorealistic examples of these
products then we should all pitch them
to these toy investors i have lined up
but i would like to present to you
the stop it
guys i looked at the charts video not me
around much longer we need to diversify
as a company i have the perfect idea
we're going to make products that's
right like boys we already make shirts
to sell stuff why toys well because toys
in the future everybody likes to play
kids are always being born i need your
help coming up with some great ideas
ideas the world's never seen before that
don't already exist you know pitch it to
some investors easy we're going to be
trillionaires dude we're getting toy
investors i got some ideas but nico how
do we create such imagery out of thin
air seemingly well we can just leverage
our abilities here of being on the
cutting edge of visual production of art
it'll combine that with our great ideas
for products we can bring the two
together so we're going to use doll e2
this new ai is nuts basically it
combines one ai that judges if text
matches an image and another ai that
generates images allowing you to write
complicated inputs and get an image that
matches what you wrote the results are
almost more realistic so i want us to
use dolly 2 to visualize perfectly
photorealistic examples of these
products do you guys have any products
that you've been like yearning for that
just don't exist i have something very
bold our kids teaching them to swim it
takes time it's tough it's challenging
but what if there was an element of fear
and danger in the water what if we put
mechanical sharks in the water to teach
our kids to swim faster mechanical
sharks in a pool with children you might
want to put full size because that seems
to work that actually works very
well what's that first one what's that
first one yeah she's she's like
one of the kids is upside down
say you want this girl to look more
terrified right you go to erase just the
face and then you just edit the
description terrified child face and it
will fill in the gaps exactly
[Laughter]
all right let's let's go hard all right
a jack daniels pacifier oh four children
oh
there she is
that's exactly what we're looking for it
comes with a little
[Music]
no it's not actual whiskey in there it's
just like for the lifestyle you know
i mean maybe you could clear up the
label more but that's all that's all we
need nailed it first try perfect i think
we should pause here i think we should
all go and make some awesome products
then we should all pitch them to these
toy investors i have lined up one of
them happens to be jordan yeah surprise
i have a side gig
yeah i'm a big time i'm big time in the
toy industry i didn't know about this oh
yeah i'm surprised are you qualified i'm
more than qualified are you qualified
that's my question well
we'll have to find out we're gonna make
the toys that everyone else are too
afraid to make the toys the kids demand
we're gonna be real all right we're
gonna be real everybody else is fake
we're gonna be real i'm gonna make the
toys that i wanted as a kid yeah i'm
gonna take risks yeah that's good let's
all take some risks
[Music]
uh well i heard you guys are doing
pitches and i have a very spectacular
pitch here today excuse me
matt i understand that you think that
you have the best pitches around town
but boy
do i have a product for you well i can't
wait to see what is in there
i'm scared actually
oh okay wow look at these what is this
well these are vessies my friend and
they're today's sponsor a sustainably
made shoe that you can wear everywhere
but jordan usually i have to hurt a lot
of animals to make my shoes you don't
have to hurt any animals with these
these are sustainably made and 100 vegan
but the thing is like my sneakers i
can't wear them in the water or when i'm
uh you know rolling around in the mud
these are 100 waterproof ah and before
you say it snow proof snow proof as well
huh every single pair of bessies are
made with this material diamond text
that keeps your feet warm in the winter
when you're cold but cool in the summer
when you're hot
i can see the distinction there yes
now if you think that you can't wear
these everywhere boy am i here to tell
you that you can wear them everywhere i
walk door-to-door selling besties every
day and look at me i'm wearing them yes
i am i wear them to the gym i wear them
around town i wear them to dinner and
when i'm on a hot date do you believe it
i do go on hot dates i take one right
now you can try it on okay will do
look at how easily it just pops onto my
feet like a glove and just how
breathable are they matt just how
breathable i feel like i have second
nostrils all right i'm gonna need those
back now no but i really like them they
feel so good on my feet don't you worry
son if you just go to bessie.com
crew you'll get 25 off of each pair
bestie.com corridor crew
all right i'm going to be going
door-to-door to other houses i got more
investments to sell you do good son keep
those feet dry stay vegan alrighty bye
now
that's cause he's a vegan
on this episode of shark bank five
investors enter the waters with dreams
of becoming the next big fish in the
child toy industry but which shop will
bite
jordan allen is not new to the game he
exploded on the scene quickly making his
billions with inventions like the baby
bolt the first all-electric shock collar
made for kids by kids
as a youtuber mark ruthlessly clawed his
way to the top of the game destroying
anyone who dared get in his way but the
fame and fortune couldn't drown out his
life's true calling mark arrives today
hungry to leave his own mark on the
industry
[Music]
our first inventor has ideas he believes
will revolutionize the toy industry and
he's not just blowing smoke
hi my name is nico
i'm an inventor of many great toys and i
can't wait to share these opportunities
with you so you may not know this but i
actually had a big hit back in the 90s
our cigarette accessory for barbie but
then federal regulators stepped in and
shut it down it's time to update the
image right it's time to bring it to the
modern day so i want to present to you
the barbie vape kit
now we've been in talks with jewel they
have a package for kids they've been
working on these vapes are also
disposable that way you have a
guaranteed incoming money stream i was
even thinking about a subscription pack
you can do so you're getting new flavors
i mean they're not actual vapes not
actual vapes just be clear here you
thought of everything just toy base
of course of course will the barbie
exhibit signs of nicotine withdrawal at
the right times you know will barbra
start like attacking her friends to get
their vapes out of their hands is that
going to be a thing that
we leave up to the child's imagination i
don't like that answer
okay okay more i got more i got more
kids love
doing the jobs that their parents do
right they love doing important jobs
like being a firefighter being an
astronaut very important jobs well you
know it's also an important job
flight crash the investigator
kids also love finding things puzzles
things like that and what do you have to
find in the crash scene the black box
so i want to present to you the lego
accident flight crash scene investigator
kit i like how bold you're being with
this one this is something that we've
actually talked about the market for
body recovery and progress has untapped
kids are already being scarred at a
younger and younger age they want to
relive those experiences in their
playroom you know if you guys want to
buy in i'm thinking like 10 bucks for
the you know 100 stake i'll get five
yeah ten's a bit steep
[Music]
deal congratulations thank you
act faster
nico walks away from this deal with a
whopping five dollars now the only crash
scene that needs investigation is this
terrible deal
our next inventor has a bag full of
rodents and a dream of a quieter
tomorrow
hello everyone
i'm a bit nervous today because i'm in
the presence of such industry moguls as
yourselves now you're a new parent fresh
baby right out the oven and the baby's
nice enough but it comes with one major
problem
that baby cries day in and day out
leaving you with no time to get that
beauty sleep that we all need well we
have a solution for that today
the hush hush baby suppressor whoa we
harness the technology of the silencer
on a real gun and put it in your baby's
mouth this
continue now this is great if that baby
just won't stop crying we have a
solution for that as well it's an
optional package
the rat mobile
interesting now we dangle ethically
murdered rats above your baby to remind
it what could happen to it if it
doesn't shut its little squeak hole do
those rats come with the toy or do you
have to source your own rats no string
them up no the rats have been
taxidermied for your convenience they're
not even alive
no they're dead no they're very dead as
i said ethically murdered i just want to
iterate that sometimes these rats do not
deter your baby from screaming it's
lungs out at night when you're trying to
sleep so we do have
one more option for you
the trebu hush
a more permanent solution
walk us through this please this is yeah
well your baby is strapped to as you can
see a trebuchet here very comfortable
for the baby it kind of looks like a toy
but if that baby starts really yapping
you know what happens i like this idea i
think it's bold i think it's brash and i
like your attitude i'm asking for
three million dollars for one percent of
the company
it's a bit rich for me do you have an
established customer base we will you
will yeah i like your vision
i like your attitude thank you it's edgy
it's exactly what i'm looking for i'm
willing to offer you
five thousand dollars for 75 of your
business
yeah yeah yes can i get some split of
the company sure what do you
what are you offering the idea the idea
25 for the idea 25 for the idea yeah is
there money i think we should loop him
in so 25 that you own and 75 that you
own yes leaves me um with five thousand
dollars in your pocket right now
[Music]
well you know what that's five thousand
dollars i didn't have so thank you very
much i appreciate your business i'll
take it i'll take it thank you so much
thank you so much
matt skillfully negotiated himself out
of 100 of his own company matt states he
has no plans for the 5 000
and is scared of the dim future he's
created for himself
this next inventor is really weird
for real like really weird
[Applause]
hi my name is ren
sorry i'm a little nervous i'm
the vietcong lego set
wow there's more there's multiple sets
they all come together
and this is a play on words because they
make holes in the ground and the lego
set accurately reproduces that
experience of
next we have
the funeral home dollhouse
new with hyper realistic toy coffins
that's pretty realistic i would die in
that i would die for that we use
patented wax technology for these doll
houses
it will not melt in your mouth
that's good it's a great delivery for
the kids who want to finish the job
we actually have a new addition to our
lineup of doll houses now come bundled
is this a working
it is working okay
but at a scale so you'll only be shocked
and not it's more like a tickle we like
to say this is fantastic however i do
have to say we did have another
invention in here that had a lego
partnered set
i know how are you going to compete with
getting a lego partnership when there
already is one i do not feel that these
markets coincide in a synergistically
effective way
i don't know what that meant yeah i lost
me too that was great
thank you for your time what you don't
want us to buy
buy what please i'll no i'll pay it's
not selling i'll i'll pay fifty thousand
pay for 100 000 150 000. i will give you
one million now if you shake my hand
can i think about it no no yes i will
give you two million if you think about
it think about it i'll tell you what
i'll just go home with you forget it we
don't need to come to my house i'll come
with you we'll get the paperwork figured
out later don't even worry about it will
it blank check you seen that movie on
disney yeah yeah if you hadn't slide
from his room
shake my hand it's a done deal what
about
the deal
as i said thank you for your time
wow
wow
bravo wren walks away from the table
with a massive two million dollar payout
while giving up nothing when asked how
he felt about the remarkable deal he
responded with good
our next inventor wants to go viral both
socially and medically with his
collection of inventions
so i'm obviously an inventor that's why
i'm here you know thankful for first and
foremost children they crave attention
they want to always feel like they're in
the picture you know they're always
vying for that undivided attention of
yours with
my first invention we can get that
attention on them
with millions of people
this camera is a tick-tock baby monitor
the first partnership which is already
secured by the way all right now see
this is not your average baby monitor
this is not just for your parents to
watch over the safety of your child but
for the whole internet
you see
these baby monitors are hooked up to the
internet 24 7 with motion detection so
that each time your baby dances in its
crib or anywhere else this camera is
facing it automatically detects that and
uploads it to your child's tick tock
account as you see this is this devil
child here by surrounding them with
these cameras here you can link them
with bluetooth as well so they all can
function simultaneously giving 360
degree coverage of your child the baby
looks so happy look at that smile that's
joy you said that you were partnered
with tick-tock already is that tick-tock
in the american headquarters or is that
tick-tock in the chinese headquarters uh
chinese headquarters yes i am in because
i was hoping you were going to say that
no one likes watching their people and
their babies more than the chinese
government in that case you're gonna
love my next product releasing hopefully
just in time for halloween this year uh
we have our very own
batsuit playset
i have a question yeah so this is in the
same vein as those candy gummy creation
kits that were popular in the 90s you're
trying to capitalize on our resurgence
of that but with soup yeah and bats well
this is a non-edible prototype but our
hope is to expand into a kind of like
easy bake oven but as you can see like
once again this is very very popular
with children here's two kids
as you can see that is that is with one
of our edible kits here where they they
can actually sip the actual broth but
you said the first batches were inedible
so what are those children eating
beats me i just sell the product i was
there for the shoot you know turning
slight concern or i guess red flag here
it appears as if the children are
changing if you just look at his eyes
well yeah
he just blinked at the wrong time you
know sometimes you blink in the middle
of a photograph once again these are
images taken in our lab they're more for
research purposes than advertisement
purposes that's fair are you laughing at
these poor kids no no i'm excited by the
idea i see his passion i love it i love
your vision i'm asking for uh ten
thousand dollars for half of everything
you saw today obviously if we if we go
into business together it's important
that we get to know each other a little
bit and so why do you have a little bit
of blood on your back
i have no idea what you're talking about
please show mark
are you the original owner of this
lab coat and this presentation
no
is there a dead body of the inventor of
the candy bat soup in the alley outside
yeah
if there's one thing i value above
everything else it's drive hostile
takeovers hostile takeovers impressive i
think you got yourself a deal all right
thanks
[Laughter]
sam's understanding of social and
medical virality nets him a cool ten
thousand dollars with our sharks today
our last inventor is tired of flaking
investors pulling his leg he's hoping
today is the day the shocks will consent
to pottering up
judges
inventors thank you for having me
it's okay take your time
suck
about six years ago my cat died from
natural causes
and he
always wanted me to make a product that
could be four kids
[Music]
to teach them about the boundaries of
physical touch
[Music]
it's okay you got this judges in this
day and age where the metoo movement has
taken hold and changed everyone's views
on personal boundaries and workplace
limitations i don't think these
limitations should have an age limit we
need to start our children early to
learn what is not okay you can twist it
you can poke it but i would like to
present to you
the stop it
this is the first ever interactive
children's toy that will teach your
child what is okay and what is not this
product features several different
customizable response spaces that will
teach your child that it is not okay to
bop it it is not okay to poke it
it is not okay
to pull it is it possible to make this
modular because as time goes on
different standards come and go to
let's say remove bop it when the the
social norms have accepted that that's
unacceptable replace it with something
like flick it this mark is why i would
love you
to become an investor on my project
because i feel like with those ideas
that you're bringing to the table in our
injection molding we can really make
something beautiful yeah it's like i'm
not even here
i'm gonna steal your ideas
i'm gonna use 3d printing instead of
injection molding your patents won't
hold up in court they're all mine now
welcome to the industry
nick's invention was stolen by mark
ironically he could do nothing to stop
it
there's so many inventions here things i
never would have thought of things that
i have already thought of things that
leave me with questions like where did
that baby go after it gets trebucheted
the stop it is fantastic design wise
ethical application i am worried about
how many times you can really play with
that before it gets a bit old but i
think we're sleeping on the tick tock
baby cam everyone knows you got to get
your social media handles claimed early
if you can automate that process get
them used to being in front of the
camera and making content every day bro
then the sooner you can get them started
on their journey to the top but you know
what sticks with me the whole time
barbie's first vape
i wasn't sold at first i really wasn't i
had ethical concerns about it but
there's so much to build off of it if
you liked what you saw
there's a little button that lets us
know that you can click it we'll keep
doing this kind of stuff and of course
subscribe and click that little bell
icon because that'll let you know when
we're uploading something new
always an exciting thing hold on sharks
these tiny electric chairs could really
do something big for our business they
want a lot of stake in the company i'm
offering you ownership full ownership of
your company but i get the electric rat
chair uh you can have the electric
chairs for the rats i had steaks last
night so i'm okay on that part though
sounds like a deal yeah
thank you